[Musique]
49-3 est une arme constitutionnelle elle
a été utilisée à de nombreuses reprises
pour être 80 fois je crois dans la 5ème
république 90
c'est la première fois depuis 30 ans
quand même qu'on réutilise le 49-3 cette
arme constitutionnelle sur le budget de
la France c'était un socialiste à
l'époque c'est un même deux social il y
avait budget de Madame cresson
et ça mal fini d'ailleurs pour pour nous
93 bon donc je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer plus tard mais ça a mal fini ça
montre surtout que c'est un gouvernement
qui aujourd'hui extrêmement fragile
d'ailleurs toute la presse nationale
aujourd'hui le démontre avec une
majorité turbulente déjà des le premier
grand texte on a vu un amendement du
modem sur les super dividendes qui avait
été voté et qui a d'ailleurs été retoqué
par le gouvernement qui d'ailleurs c'est
là aussi une première fois depuis 30 ans
a fait un choix dans les amendements
votés
en général la règle de bienséance c'est
on prend tout on rejette tout dans les
amendements déjà adopté avant la mise en
oeuvre du 49-3 là ils ont fait un tri
ils ont choisi 117 amendements une très
jolie je crois 13 amendement qui
viennent de
l'oppositionniste je crois qu'on est 3h
je suis très heureux qu'on puisse
rabaisser à 5,5 % de TVA les masques
mais c'est pas quand même l'essentiel
voilà mais c'est pas l'essentiel entre
guillemets de de la faire par contre
l'amendement de du MoDem que nous en
sommes reprendre c'est na puisque le
Sénat va pouvoir travailler on va venir
cet amendement
intéressant qui va dans le bon sens on
avait voté aussi à l'Assemblée nationale
la question des super profits se posera
naturellement la question d'un
amendement que portait piresburn madame
pierrezbone socialiste sur un crédit
d'impôt pour rentrer plus facilement
dans les EHPAD a été aussi écarté bon
voilà comme j'ai pu le dire Madame borne
lors d'une question la semaine dernière
le gouvernement est fort avec les
faibles et faible avec l'effort Bruno Le
Maire disait quand même qu'il y avait
pas eu de passage en force que le débat
avait eu lieu et c'est vrai depuis
l'année dernière il y avait une
trentaine d'heures de débats là cette
année il y en a eu 57 heures à peu près
finalement il a eu lieu ce débat autour
du budget oui mais c'est un jeu de dupe
voilà la journée des duos elle est bien
connue mais là c'était un jeu de dupe à
l'Assemblée nationale
tout le monde savait comment ça allait
se terminer
manifestement le gouvernement a décalé
le 49-3 pour laisser passer la
manifestation de dimanche celle de mardi
jusqu'au bout du départ
prenez énormément de de retard alors
c'est pas forcément du d'ailleurs au
socialiste puisque le nombre
d'amendements c'est plutôt les
républicains quand on déposé énormément
j'ai trouvé que la gauche a été très
très modérée dans dans le débat pendant
ces heures franchement rassembler très
honnêtement vous pensez que on pouvait
aller jusqu'au bout quitte à reculer les
débats parce que pendant au moins une
semaine mais il y a des délais
constitutionnels
donc mais depuis le début depuis la
première minute du débat on savait que
le 49-3 allait être tiré puisque les
républicains avaient dit qu'il ne
voteraient pas le budget et même si
c'était abstenu la majorité était de 5
ou 10 personnes mais justement quand
Elisabeth borne dit que toute façon les
dés étaient jetés comme vous le dites
également du fait de l'opposition dès le
départ des de de la nupesse du
rassemblement national ou des
républicains sur le budget donc à partir
de là comment on pouvait éviter ce 49-3
mais je vous le concède on ne peut pas
l'éviter ce qui signifie que
va-t-on arriver à 5 budgets de la
sixième puissance économique du monde
votée par un 49-30 en tout cas pas voter
adopter brutalement par un 43 c'est une
un vrai problème pour la démocratie
française et pour le fonctionnement de
nos institutions et pour vous il faut
par exemple sur le projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale il faut
malgré tout laisser continuer les débats
ou finalement il faut couper court et
utiliser 49-3 dès aujourd'hui monsieur
l'écuyer il nous a pas à chaque fois que
j'étais pas au gouvernement
je laisse prendre ses responsabilités si
c'est pour arriver au même type de de du
prix que celle que nous avons connue sur
l'Assemblée nationale avec un tri dans
les amendements adoptés il vaudrait
mieux l'utiliser au plus vite de manière
très simplement à ce que nous sénateurs
puisqu'il n'y a pas de 49-3 au Sénat
dans la mesure où il n'y a pas non plus
de motion de censure possible contre le
gouvernement au Sénat que nous sénateurs
nous puissions faire notre travail
tranquillement moi plus vite nous aurons
les textes on va la voir celui du PLF et
bientôt celui du PLFSS
plus vite nous auront le texte plus vite
nous pourrons faire nos auditions notre
travail de fond et faire des
propositions après vous vous abordez ce
texte au Sénas qu'un compromis est
possible au scénar pour vous je pense
que Hélène va vouloir faire passer ses
amendements les plus excessifs
d'ailleurs nous verrons bien sur le
projet de loi de finance sur la sécurité
sociale qui arrive d'ailleurs en premier
chez nous avant le PLF nous verrons bien
s'il remette leur amendement sur une
retraite à 65 ans 66 ans 67 ans en
termes d'âge de départ
elle vient un amendement écoutez je
pense qu'il y aura un amendement quand
même qui tend vers cela majorité
sanatoriale
je parlais de la majorité qui depuis
trois ans pose le même amendement et le
fait voter donc on verra bien qu'elle
sera la position d'ailleurs des
sénateurs proches de la macronie
vis-à-vis d'un amendement qui a priori
va dans le sens souhaitée par Emmanuel
Macron donc il va y avoir des moments
nucléaires et la majorité sénatoriale
que le compromis va être difficile à
trouver qu'avec le gouvernement jusqu'à
nouvel ordre il n'y a pas de compromis
possibles avec la majorité de droite
voudront nous amendements nous porterons
les amendements défendus par nos amis de
l'Assemblée nationale nous aurons nos
propres amendements on va revenir par
exemple sur la réintégration d'un ISF
climatique dans notre pays on sait bien
que LR le refusera naturellement la
question qui est posée pour nous au
travers de ces deux budgets c'est
comment répartis la richesse nationale
cette richesse elle existe je me renvoie
au salaire de Monsieur pouyanet
d'ailleurs devrait changer de
communiquant parce que si c'est
moi je l'ai pas apprécié mais je le
trouve indécent vraiment indécent dire
mais oh vous savez en 2020 j'ai baissé
mon salaire et donc c'est normal que je
réaugmente quand on est à 500.000 euros
de salaire par mois c'est-à-dire
300 fois plus qu'un seul SMIC je me dis
quand même que non il est fatigué et moi
je sais pas une rémunération qui est
mirobolante pour un patron du CAC 40
d'ailleurs ce serait bien d'ailleurs
qu'on fasse la différence entre les
patrons et les grands patrons
les patrons vous êtes du Nord je suis du
Nord et ce sont des patrons qui engagent
du risque personnel qui engage leur
argent personnel les grands patrons du
CAC 40 ce sont des salariés
ça marche ils sont hyper payés ça marche
pas ils continuent à être hyper payer et
puis on les licencié avec un parachute
doré c'est pas pour moi le même patrons
le patron qui engage sa responsabilité
et qui engage ses finances qui engagent
parfois sa maison pour défendre sa boîte
il aurait à mon avis plus à être reconnu
aujourd'hui de notre pays et de Total
énergie ça va mieux dans les
stations-service environ 20% néanmoins
on connaisse encore des difficultés ça
va mieux dans votre région des
Hauts-de-France ici on est passé de 55%
à 20%, est-ce que le gouvernement a eu
raison procéder assez réquisition le
gouvernement a utilisé une arme qui a
d'ailleurs été reconnue par le deux
tribunaux administratifs sauf erreur de
ma part est-ce que ça règle le problème
de fond la réponse est non bien sûr et
je suis content pour les automobilistes
vous savez moi il y a il y a dix jours
pour faire ma tournée dans mon
comportement je me suis levé à 6h30 du
matin pour aller trouver de l'essence et
j'ai eu de la chance pas très loin de
chez moi à Lille très bien donc j'ai
aussi subi les conséquences mais la
vraie question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi dans l'intérêt là pourquoi le
gouvernement s'obstine à ne pas vouloir
une grande conférence à l'arrière qui
permettrait au moins de poser les choses
sur la table pourquoi le gouvernement
symboliquement n'engage pas une démarche
vis-à-vis des super profits
on parle beaucoup des énergéticiens très
bien mais je vais vous parler d'une
autre boîte qui est CMA-CGM CMA CGM elle
est à Marseille un peu loin de chez nous
chez les cuilliers je vous le conseille
mais c'est elle qui est spécialiste sur
le le portage des containers et les
voyages en mer
ils ont réussi ce coût extraordinaire
prétexte de l'inflation et de et de
l'Ukraine pour passer de 2500 euros à la
location d'un container à 18000 euros
purement artificiellement après ces
revenus à des normes ils ont fait un
geste suivant les demandes du
gouvernement ils ont été parmi ceux qui
ont fait oui mais à partir de quoi à
partir de 7 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices sur un semestre soit 240 fois
plus que le bénéfice de l'année
précédente donc si vous voulez l'argent
existe je souhaite qu'il soit mieux
répartis tout simplement et si les
salariés estiment qu'aujourd'hui
demander 7 ou 8 % et bien c'est assez
normal je pense qu'il faut que le
gouvernement dise et pas que disent mais
amen parce qu'il a dit le gouvernement
mais surtout
la meilleure contrainte c'est de donner
un signe le signe c'est le SMIC le SMIC
est finalement le paramètre de base pour
pouvoir augmenter les salaires et le
gouvernement s'y oppose madame borne a
eu d'ailleurs cette ce propos toujours
dans la même question d'actualité que je
lui ai posé elle m'a répondu mais de
quoi vous allez vous monsieur canard
nous avons augmenté le SMIC de 8 % alors
que l'inflation est de 6 mais de qui
elle se moque pour un smicard pour un
smicard l'inflation n'est pas 10% même
pas de 8% l'alimentation est à 20 ou 25%
votre journal monsieur Lecuyer un panier
de la ménagère moyen 25% l'augmentation
en un an l'électricité elle va donc
combien le gaz l'essence donc pour un
smicard l'inflation elle est au moins
20%. le mois de le mois de janvier on
parle on parle très fortement aussi
d'une d'une explosion sociale puisque ce
conjuguera à la fois les prix du
carburant les prix des des énergies du
gaz de l'électricité est-ce que on peut
craindre une explosion cet hiver je ne
la crains pas je pense qu'elle va avoir
lieu
je pense qu'elle va avoir lieu parce que
et à un moment donné quand vous pourrez
quand vous ne pourrez pas vous chauffer
quand vous pourrez pas offrir plus que
des pâtes à vos enfants quand le 15 du
mois c'est déjà
le défi le découvert qui arrive qui
arrive là aussi une étude récente a
montré que les personnes ont découvert
étaient liées à 30% au niveau de
l'inflation c'est-à-dire que l'inflation
cause le tiers des découvertes dans
notre pays oui il y a plus qu'un risque
c'est une réalité qui malheureusement
risque s'imposer et quelque chose qui
risque de s'ajouter à ça c'est le débat
sur les retraites puisque le projet de
leur projet de loi est attendu en début
d'année alors vous avez rencontré avec
Boris Vallot le député la première
ministre lundi pour évoquer cette cette
réforme qu'est-ce que vous en tirez
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à entrer dans
une logique de co-construction avec le
gouvernement jamais enfin il y a une
séparation des pouvoirs l'exécutif
propose le législatif dispose donc nous
ne rentrons pas dans une logique de
co-construction d'ailleurs
communiste nous le demande pas elle me
l'a dit clairement elle nous a dit
clairement avec Maurice elle nous a dit
qu'il y aurait un projet de loi que nous
serions associés en tant que
parlementaire au début de la
concertation et du résultat de cette
constatation dans une quinzaine de jours
pour l'instant ça se passe plutôt bien
avec les syndicats puisqu'on parle de
choses plutôt positives la question de
la pénibilité de l'usure au travail etc
la question qui la question qui fâche
celle des 65 ans n'est toujours pas
abordé quand elle va être abordée je
pense que sera un peu plus compliqué
donc le projet de loi va passer 49-3
probablement le gouvernement a décidé
d'une réforme paramétrique et non pas
systémique comme dans l'ancienna
précédent on aurait pu parler de la
réforme de la retraite par point c'était
intéressant c'était un vrai débat là on
est sur la brutalité encore une fois et
surtout qui va qui va morfler
permettez-moi l'expression bien ça va
être les ouvriers notamment les
ouvrières ça va être effectivement les
femmes seules les carrières hachées 65
ans c'est relever de la vie aux années
je pèse mes mots enlever de la vie aux
années parce que nous savons que un
ouvrier c'est six ans d'espérance de vie
de moins que
qu'un cadre et que une retraite en bonne
santé n'existe que de 60 à 65 ans grosso
modo après les risques commencent à
arriver donc non c'est une mesure pour
gagner quoi 12 13 14 milliards d'euros
dans les pires hypothèses du comité
d'orientation des retraites dans les
pires des hypothèses nous nous avons
défendu une réforme avec Marisol
Touraine dans le quinquennat précédent
qui amène à 43 années d'amnité pour
d'ici quelques années d'ici 2030 ça
suffisait largement pour équilibrer les
retraites voilà c'est un combat
idéologique que mène le gouvernement moi
j'ai pas peur du mot est-ce que vous
irez jusqu'à des défilés avec d'autres
membres de la gauche notamment la et les
filles qui préparent une autre marche
on la deuxième quinzaine de novembre
propre probablement est-ce que vous y
serez
que derrière les syndicats ça a toujours
été ma tradition je crois la Charte
d'Amiens 1906
il y a une séparation entre le syndicats
et les partis politiques nous partis
politiques nous avons d'autres formes de
moyens de lutter le Parlement les
collectivités locales les débats publics
comme nous le faisons ici sur la chaîne
publique Sénat
et Monsieur général
à côté de Jean-Luc Mélenchon je ne
souhaite pas que les partis politiques
prennent la place des syndicats je le
dis très simplement je n'ai pas défilé
dimanche volontairement parce que je
considère que c'était pas ma place de
défiler dans un mouvement initier les
syndicats doivent être respectés et ce
sont les syndicats qui doivent porter la
parole des salariés et pas à sa place
pour vous
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
moi je respecte la décision je vous
parle de ma position personnelle une
partie a décidé de défiler je le
respecte mais titre personnel je ne le
souhaite pas justement puisqu'on parle
de votre partie hier 1500 cadres du PS
dont une centaine de mètres 35
parlementaires dont des sénateurs de
votre groupe on publie une tribune dans
l'Express pour soutenir Olivier Faure du
prochain congrès c'est une première de
soutenir
le premier secrétaire moi je suis membre
du Parti socialiste depuis très
longtemps trop longtemps on dirait un
certain mais mon premier congrès c'était
le Congrès de Nantes en 1975 donc on ne
sait pas encore né peut-être
donc j'ai un peu de recul et c'est la
première fois que je vois un texte de
soutien à la personne du patron du Parti
socialiste
selon moi avec la photo du premier
secrétaire j'ai même vu des affiches
avec la tête du premier secrétaire bon
le culte de la personnalité est une
chose c'est pas ma tradition peut-être
que c'est l'évolution du du Parti
socialiste moi je défends des idées je
défends des collectifs qui sont toujours
incarnés à un moment donné bien
évidemment qui a une incarnation vous
nous dire qu'aujourd'hui fort est
affaibli la tribune la tribune
pour la démarche initié par Olivier fort
pour sa personne il aurait sauvé le
parti notamment en raison du kata de la
catastrophe pour nous politiques et
électorale de 10 avril dernier ça il
faut le reconnaître moi je j'étais
content quand on est un accord avec la
gauche la vraie question pour nous
socialiste elle est simple c'est est-ce
qu'il faut retrouver une Palace centrale
tout le monde le dit y compris
d'ailleurs les amis d'Olivier Faure et
heureusement parce que la nuit pêche
aujourd'hui c'est 30% et la question
pour nous toutes et nous tous
socialistes c'est comment on va chercher
les 20% qui nous manquent pour redevenir
un parti de gouvernement aujourd'hui
nous jouons un peu en Ligue 2 disons-le
simplement et c'est dommage parce que
nous avons des joueurs de Ligue 1 et les
joueurs de Ligue 1 ce sont nos
grands-mères ce sont nos présentes
départements
il y a le maire de Montpellier vous
l'avez peut-être vu dans lequel de la
fausse qui a jugé dans le dans le Figaro
que la direction assurée par Olivier
Faure était une impasse pour la gauche
est-ce que vous le suivez sur cette
position moi je ne suis pas un débat
pour ou contre Olivier fort ceci pour un
débat d'idées et je suis plutôt rassuré
alors la ligne d'Olivier fort est-elle
une impasse pour la gauche la ligne de
l'ifort devrait être éclairci est-ce que
nous sommes là pour être derrière un
leadership de LFI parce qu'elle est
fille a réussi un coup extraordinaire de
transformer un vote du 10 avril en Alpha
Omega des équilibres à l'avenir de la
gauche je ne le crois pas les 22% de
Monsieur Mélenchon ne sont pas que ces
22% à lui il y a eu beaucoup de vote
utile on le sait bien il y a eu des
sondages qui ont amené à ce vote utile
donc la réalité passera par aussi
d'autres élections il y a une échéance
qui arrive qui est l'échéance latoriale
qui est basée sur une autre légitimité
celle des élections municipales
départementales et régionales et
aujourd'hui j'ai pu vous dire mais je
pense que je ne trahis aucun secret que
aucun candidat qui aurait l'estampille
et les filles ne pourraient être élu sur
son nom il n'y a pas assez de grands
électeurs dans chemin des 41
départements renouvelables donc ce que
vous dites vous dites
c'est pareil
ce sera derrière nous mais la vraie
question qui se pose
la décision qui sera prise par la
nouvelle direction
mon envie elle est simple c'est que il
n'y aura en tout cas tel tant que je
serai présent du groupe je ne
sacrifierai pour aucun accord aucun
sortant du Parti socialiste aucun
sortant de mon groupe j'en ai 33 qui
vont être soumis à renouvellement aucun
de 100 ans s'il doit y avoir un accord
ça doit être un accord gagnant-gagnant
gagnant-gagnant
et les filles a imposé aux trois autres
partenaires un score un accord pardon
basé sur un score moi je dis puisque
l'arithmétique a fondé dans un sens il
faut qu'elle fonctionne dans un autre
sens donc je n'ai rien contre l'idée
d'un sénateur et les filles ou deux ou
trois la question c'est que ça doit être
dans ouais c'est ça non mais
arithmétiquement ça me paraît compliqué
la question qui nous est posée c'est
est-ce que cela est possible
en faisant gagner globalement la gauche
aujourd'hui nous sommes je crois 95 ou
94 sénateurs de gauche PC pS Les Verts
est-ce que par un accord nous serons
sans dix-120 130 C'est ça la vraie
question politique et je me limite à
cela par contre je ne veux pas permettre
que sur un tapis vert et bien ce soit
des sortants de mon groupe il soit
sacrifiés sur un accord hypothétique
vous défendez une troisième voie c'est
clair vous avez publié une tribune
intitulée refondation est-ce que vous
envisagez vous personnellement de porter
une motion prochain congrès Patrick
moi je ne suis rien je suis dans un
collectif
je sais pas une fausse bon mais je dis
simplement que nous avons bâti cette
cette ce texte qui sera une contribution
générale dans les prochains jours dans
une démarche collective qui est
différente de celle portée par la
majorité
actuelle du Parti socialiste c'est vrai
puisque nous croyons à l'Union mais ce
que nous voulons c'est une union où le
parti socialiste retrouve toute sa place
centrale parce que nous pensons que
c'est lui et seul qui pourra ramener un
jour la gauche au pouvoir et que c'est
pas l'extrême gauche qui qui pourra le
faire dans notre pays à se transformer
en émotion potentiellement je le dis
simplement avec un candidat avec un avec
un numéro 1
des bas collectif moi ce que je sais
c'est candidat vous apportez cette
motion donc ça sera pas bon ce sera ça
pourrait être votre confiance mais ce
sera à mon avis je ne pense pas non plus
nous avons trois porte-parole
aujourd'hui le maire de Rouen Nicolas
meilleur Signol clairefitta qui est une
vif présidente de la région Occitanie ce
qui est aussi un signe par rapport à
donc
notre ancienne députée de Paris qui a
été la sacrifiée d'ailleurs de l'accord
avec avec les filles avec les filles et
la nuque en général
donc trois porte-parole trois jeunes une
nouvelle génération est-ce que entre
guillemets le futur
la future incarnation sera celle là
parmi ces trois personnes ou quelqu'un
d'autre nous le verrons bien vous savez
le Congrès c'est fin janvier donc il y a
un peu d'eau qui va couler sous les
ponts d'ici là ce que vous nous dites
clairement c'est que oui il y aura une
troisième motion
voire même une cinquième portée par qui
alors on parle de Valérie rabot à la
Mirabeau j'entends que Laurence
Rossignol pourrait aussi seatrice de
l'Oise pourrait porter des idées ce que
je veux c'est que mon Congrès ne soit
pas plié d'avance
une fracture c'est surtout ça parce que
est-ce qu'on risque pas finalement
d'avoir encore une fois c'est parler de
mon âge de mammouth en tant que en tant
que militant socialiste moi j'ai connu
des congrès avec 7 huit motions soumises
tant mieux qu'il y a un vrai débat au
sein du PS un congrès plié d'avance
avant même qu'il ait commencé je n'en
veux pas et bien plus il y aura de
textes plus les militants pourront
choisir et c'est tant mieux qui reste
qui reste malheureusement dernière
question rapidement oui l'ancien
ministre des Sports que que vous êtes
forcément à un regard particulier sur la
Coupe du monde de football qui va se
dérouler au Qatar est-ce que vous
regarderez les joueurs de l'équipe de
France non vous regarderez
cette coupe du monde d'ici en 2010 dans
des conditions
cette coupe du monde donc c'est une
une
anomalie sur le plan climatique bon
écologique vous le savez c'est une
aberration sur le plan des droits
humains
c'est vraiment le pays des droits de
l'homme doit pas être dans les tribunes
moi je finissais pas naturellement et
donc je demande au gouvernement de
participer à aucune manifestation
officielle
il faut pas pénaliser les sportifs
sportifs ils se préparent à ça depuis
des années ils ont passé les épreuves il
faut qu'ils puissent aller jusqu'au bout
j'espère qu'ils ont est-ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment se contenter
de cette réflexion là les Jeux
olympiques d'hiver ils ont eu lieu selon
dans des conditions écologiques
déplorables en Chine dans un pays qui a
des quelques problèmes avec les droits
de l'homme et pourtant on l'a suivi et
les Jeux asiatiques
sont prévues en Arabie Saoudite et bien
donc il faut dire STOP il faut dire
que quand on a 6000 morts quand on a des
cimetières autour de ces stades y aller
c'est terrible et moi de manière très
modeste je vous le reconnais et bien
j'ai décidé en mon âme et conscience ce
sera un créateur c'est un crève-cœur
j’écouterai les résultats mais je ne
regarderai pas les émissions merci
Patrice canner merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin regardez une
de la Voix du Nord Julien fouquer un
village dans le tourbillon du meurtre de
Lola
merci Patrick canard
[Musique]